بمناسبه اليوم العالمي للمتبرعين بالدم
تقدم منظمه الصحه العالميه حقائقها
وارقاما مهمه حيث تجمع على الصعيد العالمي
تبرعات الدم بمقدار مئه وثمانيه عشر مليون
و500 الف تبرع 40% منها تجمع في البلدان
المرتفعه الدخل التي تاوي نسبه
16% من سكان العالم في البلدان المنخفضه
الداخلي يتلقى الاطفال دون سن الخامسه
عمليات نقل دم بنسبه تصل الى 54 بالمئه
وفي المجموع يجمع 79 بلدا
90% من امدادات الدم من المتبرعين طوعا
دون مقابل وهي الفئه الاكثر امانا في جوده
الدم في المقابل يجمع 54 بلدا اكثر من 50%
من امداداته من الدم من الاسر او
المتبرعين بالدم لقاء اجر كما تظهر
البيانات ان نسبه 33% من عمليات التبرع
بالدم هي من النساء
وتوصي المنظمه بالزاميه فحص جميع كميات
الدم المتبرع بها للتاكد من خلوها من
الايدز وفيروسات التهاب الكبد والتهاب
الكبد سي ومرض الزهري
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات